(playful music)
- Maybe you want to open
the conversation with
inquiring about pronouns.
- With kindness and love.
- I think there's nothing
more frustrating than
someone just seeing you
as the sum of your gender.
- You would address a trans person
like you would address any other person,
you would treat them as a person.
- You just say "hi."
Start with that.
(upbeat music)
- Everybody has their
own nuanced definition
of what transness means to them.
- It's basically identifying as
a gender that you were
not assigned at birth.
- Being born in the gender that I
really just don't fell comfortable in.
- If you're gonna give
it a name, strength.
I believe that us transgendered women,
we have a strength unlike any other.
(upbeat music)
- A trans person looks like
any other type of person.
That's like asking what
does a man look like?
Or what does a woman look like,
or what does a child look like?
There are so many variables.
- Trans people come in all genders, all--
- [Both] Shapes and sizes.
- All colors, and also, you know,
you don't need to have
transitioned to be transgender.
Trans people aren't
necessarily always visible.
- Everybody's got a certain look.
There's no particular uniform.
- Just like all cis
women don't look alike,
all trans women don't look alike.
- I mean, look at you and I, honey.
Only thing we share is a little mocha.
- My transition was an evolution.
I knew from an early age
that I felt something.
I didn't have the
language to articulate it.
- I think there's always
been an element of me
that always knew.
- I knew at 19 that it was
possible to transition,
and I didn't transition until 35.
- Like you said, everyone's
journey is completely different.
I mean, I always knew.
- I was attracted to feminine things
when I was around five,
but my parents didn't know,
I didn't even know the
term trans or transgender.
I was just told, "no, you
shouldn't be into Barbies,
"you should be into GI Joe."
- I was into My Little Pony.
(upbeat music)
- Not all transgender
people are heterosexual
and neither are they all gay.
- Gender and sexuality
are not the same thing.
- I've always been about beauty
doesn't have a sex for me,
so at the end of the day, it's
like what I'm gonna remember
is whether or not you are a nice person.
- Not all trans people take hormones
or decide to take hormones.
- I'm like "give it to me, baby."
- I love my 'mones.
- A year into my recognition to myself,
I was just like, this is
everything that I've always known,
but brought it together,
like it brought my levels
and everything together, so in a sense,
it brought me right for my blood type.
- Some trans people choose to use hormones
because they want to have
masculinizing characteristics
added to their body, or they want to have
feminizing characteristics in their body
and they don't naturally produce those.
- Being trans does not
require having surgery.
- So you kind are like forced,
like okay, I need to
have all these surgeries
so I can blend in and
people can accept me,
but really, I didn't have to
have any of the surgeries,
I just needed to love
myself and be accepted.
- Everyone's journey
is completely different
and I think that how you
feel inside is exactly that,
and if you feel like
you've got to do something
to make that inside
feel right, then you do.
- It's all about the process of
changing your body if you
want to to make yourself
feel more comfortable and
peaceful within your own mind.
- You can be trans and never
have any type of surgery,
never do anything at all,
maybe just change your
name, change your pronouns.
You can do whatever, you can self-define.
(calm music)
- Dating while trans is a nightmare.
It is so annoying.
I mean, it's not like
there's not people out there,
it's just a mine field.
- Either extreme fetishism
or extreme rejection,
there's really no middle ground for me.
- Assertive woman is very different
than being a touchy-feely guy.
Now I'm a creep, so I had
to like learn all of those
kind of nuanced behavior patterns.
- A lot of guys that approach
me assume that I am cis,
so do I tell him immediately?
Do I tell him via text, do I call him?
Do we meet up at Starbucks?
It's so much that runs through my mind
as far as, okay, this man is feeling me,
how am I going to
deliver this news to him?
- It's scary because
you're going to a situation
where someone doesn't
necessarily know your background,
and I don't fear for myself necessarily,
but for trans women,
that's a very dangerous
situation to be in.
You know, women do get killed.
- My first thought is we're
not accepted by society.
- That is a very good question.
Why do black people get murdered?
Why is anyone out there coming outside
with their face crooked,
taking someone else's life
because of whatever it is
that they're going through?
- Trans women of color are
being murdered left and right
and they're not getting
the same opportunity as
a cis person or a cis white person.
- The reality of the matter is
a lot of the murders are
based in stigma and shame.
- There's a lot of fear in
who does this person make me,
and what does it say about my masculinity
and who I am in front of everybody else.
- There's so many reasons
why trans women are murdered,
but ultimately it comes down to prejudice.
It comes to inequality,
and it comes to lack of understanding
about trans people and the
men that find us attractive.
(upbeat music)
- Of course you can be religious.
I identify and believe in Buddhism
and I've practiced that
since I was a child.
- Religion's meant to be for everybody.
- Anybody can be religious.
(laughs)
- Transitioning was like a
spiritual experience for me.
I finally felt like I was my whole self,
and as a result, I found
a relationship with
a higher power of my understanding.
(calm music)
- The way that my mind is formed
has been a blessing and that's, um,
a lot of that is down to being trans
and empathizing, and coming into contact
with so many amazing
people that I don't know
if I would have met if I was cis.
- Being able to look at yourself
and, because you have to, a lot of times,
you're like, why am I different?
What is wrong with me?
And so you spend a lot
of time thinking about
who you are.
- I love being trans.
Having a human experience,
and I got to be both sexes.
- At the end of the day,
none of us are worth anything
if we don't love ourself.
That has everything
with how it is that you
hold your head up and how proud you are.
- The thing I love most about being trans
is getting this complete 360-degree view
of what it means to be a human being.
- But what I love most
about being trans for myself
has just been my journey
throughout womanhood
and sharing stories
with fellow trans women
and even cis women and seeing
differences and similarities.
- I love that people are
googling these questions,
because that means you're
curious and you want to learn
something about the trans community.
- You can find out more that
you ever will on google,
I swear, by actually speaking to people.
(calm music)